[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
37 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hey, Francesc.
How are you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very good.
Happy to have Carter
back for one more week.
MARK MANDEL: Just one episode,
I'd like you to be like,
yeah, I'm a little down today.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm a little sad.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm just a
very happy person in general.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So yeah, we're going to have
Carter keep on telling us
about Kubernetes
1.3, but specifically
about the new things that are
coming to Google Container
Engine, container
reading with a K, so GKE.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so
we've got a whole bunch
of new features and new
stuff above and beyond
what already came with
1.3 in Kubernetes,
so we're going to have
a chat about that.
And there's some pretty
cool stuff in there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And also during
the interview, we
will also mention, how do you
get started with Kubernetes?
What are the best ways to learn
the basics, and et cetera.
So regardless are if you are an
expert that wants to know more
about the latest
things, or if you
want to really
learn the basics, I
think this interview will
be very good for you.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And then at the end,
we will have a
question of the week.
And for the second, maybe
third, I don't count anymore,
week in a row, the question
will be on Kubernetes.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, well it's
such an interesting topic.
I just can't avoid it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I know.
No, people keep on asking
questions about Kubernetes,
which is great.
I'm very happy to
answer all of those,
and I keep on learning
by answering them.
So yay.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
so we're going
to have a little chat about
how we do local development
with Kubernetes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
But before that,
we're going to start
with a cool thing of the week.
And the cool thing of the
week this week comes from you,
and it comes clearly from
you, because it involves
your favorite,
favorite product, which
is-- what is the name again?
MARK MANDEL: Deployment Manager.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Deployment
Manager, Google Cloud
Deployment Manager.
And it is related to MongoDB.
So the question
is, OK, so I want
to run MongoDB on
Google Cloud Platform.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What is
the easiest/best way to get
started?
MARK MANDEL: So this is
actually quite interesting.
So there are a few ways that
you could create MongoDB
on Google Cloud Platform.
Obviously you could fire up
your compute engine instances
and sort of manually
install it, do it that way--
not necessarily a
difficult way to do it.
We have Google Cloud Launcher to
quickly create and sort of test
a MongoDB replica set.
That works, but to a degree
it's a little harder to manage.
Once it's already up, if
you want to upgrade it,
it becomes a little more
difficult. It's not like that.
However, what we have, and there
is a blog post that comes along
with this that is on Google
Cloud Platform's blog,
that provisions and installs
MongoDB Cloud Manager, which
is a MongoDB tool for
running and running a replica
set of MongoDB in the cloud.
But we use Cloud
Deployment Manager
templates to basically
bootstrap that and keep
that up and running and
get that up and started.
So you kind of get the
best of both worlds.
You get almost the speed and
simplicity of using, say,
like Cloud Launcher.
But now you've got something
that's managed by MongoDB.
It's hooked into their services.
And then so if you want to
run MongoDB in the cloud,
it seems like a really
nice way to do it
at production and at scale.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
That sounds very cool.
And yeah, the blog post will
be linked from the show notes
as always.
Great.
So I think it is time to go
back to our long interview
with Carter Morgan.
So he keeps on letting us
know more about GKE 1.3.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
I don't think we've talked
to him in a long time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Let's go for that.
So since we enjoyed last week so
much talking to Carter Morgan,
we're back again to talk more
about Kubernetes and GKE.
Hi, Carter.
How are you doing?
CARTER MORGAN: Doing
well, Francesc.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Long time, no see.
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah,
feels like I never left.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, for those that
didn't listen to the
previous episode,
we discussed a little bit
about all the new things that
come with Kubernetes 1.3,
and one of those things
was more nodes
and bigger things,
and all of those things.
And it was all related to
Kubernetes in the wild.
You can run whatever you
want to run it, on GCE, GKE,
but also on Amazon or
wherever you want to run it.
Today we're going to be talking
more specifically about GKE.
So what is there?
The first question could
be, is Kubernetes 1.3
available on GKE?
CARTER MORGAN: Yep.
I just updated all my
clusters last night
so I can test out
all the new features.
It's available for everybody.
If you don't know, GKE is
Google Container Engine.
That's a C, which is
weird, because they
had the name taken.
But it's a hosted
version of Kubernetes.
So they're basically
host and master for you
on Google Compute Instances.
You don't get charged
for that, and you just
get charged for compute
instances you use.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So other than all the
new features on 1.3,
that will be available
on GKE, what other things
are we expecting to have?
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah, so there's
a lot of Container Engine
specifics now.
There seems like the new
container VM images-- so
what that is is a more
secure, stripped-down image.
So since it's
stripped down, there's
less places for
attackers to get at.
It comes with auto updates.
It's just basically optimized
for a container environment.
MARK MANDEL: So before,
clusters were running--
I think it was Debian.
So if I fire up a
new GKE cluster now,
this is going to run this new
image, or how does that work?
CARTER MORGAN: You
have to select it.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
CARTER MORGAN: And
then I think they're
all prefix GCI so you can tell
the difference when you look.
I forget the exact command
off the top of my head,
but they're prefix
GCI for the ones.
And this is in beta.
But this is one
of those features
that I think-- again, more
security, more better, right?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So this kind of
makes me think about basically
macro-- now unikernels.
We had an episode on
that not that long ago.
So the idea is that you're going
to be removing things like FTP
and the services
that are actually not
related to Kubernetes.
Is that the main idea, or--
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah,
that's the basic idea.
So you're saying, what do
I need to run containers?
What do containers do often?
Let's keep that.
Let's get rid of the rest.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And if you
need those back in, [? APT ?]
[? getinstall ?] could
good still work, or--
CARTER MORGAN: You know, I
haven't checked the specifics.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
CARTER MORGAN: So I'm not
sure what they restrict.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
MARK MANDEL: That's fair enough.
OK, but at least then
it sort of limits
attack vectors for
security, makes it easier
to update for the
Google Cloud team,
and probably makes their
lives a whole lot easier
across the board.
CARTER MORGAN: Right.
And then it also comes with
auto updating features.
So as new security
fixes come in,
you get that updated
automatically to your cluster.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
Cool.
What else?
So other than container VM
images, I've heard about SSTs.
There's a lot of people
excited about that.
They need more
speed, more better.
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah.
Want to go fast?
Yeah, so in GKE and GCE,
you have local SSTs,
so you can use those now.
They just go a lot faster.
MARK MANDEL: There's
not a lot to say.
You just get SSTs.
That's good.
CARTER MORGAN: It's
all good there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I'm imagining that with
the pet sets and local SST,
now if you want to run
things like big databases
on Kubernetes, it will be
much faster than before.
MARK MANDEL: So I know we've
had a really big push internally
around IAM and access control.
I know there were some new
authorization facilities that
were in place with Kubernetes.
Has that been extended
to IAM now as well?
CARTER MORGAN: Right.
So they added role-based
access, or RBAC.
And now with IAM
and GKE, what you
get is all the
API calls now, you
can say, OK, who has
access to do this?
Who can start up a new pod?
Who can delete stuff?
So that's support in GKE now.
What IAM is is identity
and access management.
MARK MANDEL: So
that's really cool.
I mean, when you're running
a really large team,
especially if you have
a really large cluster,
you want to have control
over who can do what
within that cluster.
I think that sounds
really, really powerful
and really useful.
CARTER MORGAN: So the
coolest thing about IAM
is that instead of role-based
stuff where you say,
I have an admin and the
admin can do everything,
I have a user, he
can do three things,
now you get a lot more granular.
So I can say, Mark
can create clusters.
Francesc can delete them.
And me, Carter, I
can do everything.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
that makes sense.
I wouldn't want to have the
power to delete clusters.
That sounds scary.
[LAUGHTER]
CARTER MORGAN: A lot
of responsibility.
MARK MANDEL: It's
a lot of-- I don't
need that kind of
responsibility in my life.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
also related to this,
when you say role-based
access, we talked about people.
But is it also good practice,
like security practice,
to say, oh, this instance--
all of these kind of instances
have access to these power
of the API, but not others?
Or is that something
that you've seen?
CARTER MORGAN: I
haven't seen it.
I haven't seen it,
so I don't want
to comment on best
practices for security.
I know that you can
set up service accounts
and say who can access what.
And so someone in your
organization would set that up.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
All right.
MARK MANDEL: I know
you were getting
quite excited about node pools.
CARTER MORGAN: Yes.
OK, I really like node pools.
So what node pools are is kind
of like cluster federation
lite.
So one of the
things you can have,
instead of having
different clusters,
here you can have
different node pools that
can be replicated across zones.
So with cluster federation,
like we talked about last week,
you could have clusters
in different regions,
like Asia, Europe, US.
You could also have them across
different cloud providers,
like AWS, GCP, or even
on prem, like OpenStack.
Here what we're going
to get is something
replicated across
zones, so if you're
worried that a zone might fail.
It's lightweight.
It's not the same as
a cluster federation.
But what you can also do
is have different types
of nodes in your cluster.
So I could say, maybe
I have a database
and I want a 200-gigabyte
machine for it
to sit on so it could
eat up that data.
But my front-end
application or my server app
only needs like a 10-gig,
pretty small instance.
So now I can do that.
That's very powerful.
MARK MANDEL: And I take it
you've got control there
as well in terms of
where your pods end up
sitting within that node pool.
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah,
so there's affinity.
And you can also use selectors.
So you could say, basically,
when you use node pools,
you get a label
attached to the node.
It's an actual machine.
And you can use that
in your pod to select
which one it's going to sit on.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, that
sounds super useful,
being able to
specifically say, hey,
this container should be
on this type of thing.
Now, to play devil's
advocate a little bit,
does that go against the
idea of cattle versus pets?
Or is that still in the
same cattle category?
CARTER MORGAN: I think when
you have persistent data,
you no longer have cattle,
because data matters.
Data isn't stateless.
So maybe the whole
idea of persistent data
goes against cattle.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
But still something to consider
when dealing with node pools
and how you structure stuff.
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah,
that's a great question.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
There are pros and cons.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
I wonder if having
node pools plus having
local SSTs is something that
can make it like, you can
say all my web servers
are going to be running
on the light nodes.
But then I have the
nodes with local SST
that are going to be
running whatever, [? ATD ?]
or whatever database
you want to use.
Sounds like a good
thing to have.
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah, that
sounds like a perfect use case.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, nice.
Something else related also
to nodes, not node pools.
It is node auto scaling.
CARTER MORGAN: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I've seen
these many times before,
and it was like you need
to make it-- you need
to write your own auto scaler.
It was quite hard.
Seems like we fixed
that, and we have it now
as a part of
Kubernetes-- part of GKE.
CARTER MORGAN:
GKE, yeah, and GCE.
So basically now, there was
already horizontal pod auto
scaling, so if you used up
too many resources on pods,
you could scale up a pod.
That was built into Kubernetes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What
is-- for our listeners,
what is horizontal scaling
versus vertical scaling?
CARTER MORGAN: Good
question, good question.
So horizontal
scaling is scaling up
more instances of
your application,
whereas vertical scaling is
scaling up more resources
for your instances to live on.
So now in GKE, what you get
is a vertical auto scaling.
So we can say, I
have this pod that I
can't schedule right
now, because there's not
enough space for it.
GKE's smart enough, our
computer's smart enough
to go and look and say, if
I were to add another node,
could I schedule this pod?
And if so, then schedule it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
CARTER MORGAN: And
so there's a few use
cases for this, actually,
if you think about it.
Take a CI service,
continuous integration.
It's going to be really
busy Monday through Friday,
if you're not one of
those companies that's
making people work all weekend.
And it's going to wind
down on the weekend.
So why waste money having
all these resources up
over the weekend?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
CARTER MORGAN: You can
have your nodes scale up
while everyone's
in there working,
and then over the weekend wind
back down and save you money.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, that
sounds like a very, very
good use of your money.
I'm wondering,
how does this work
with, again, stateful apps?
CARTER MORGAN: OK.
Yeah, I-- hm.
I know there are some
things that are still
getting ironed out, like we
just talked about node affinity
or using node selectors.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
CARTER MORGAN: Well, so if I
add a label, or a few other
[? QTTL ?] commands
to a node, that's
not going to get replicated
when I scale up a pod or not.
So if you're using that
to say, I want my node
to sit on this pod
because it's SST
and I want it to go fast in
this stateful reason, that's
not going to work.
MARK MANDEL: I suppose
that makes sense, too,
like if you're auto scaling,
at least right now, especially,
if you're auto
scaling out a cluster,
it's for mostly stateless apps.
I mean, that's the stuff you
really want to grow and shrink.
It's not for stuff that's
like-- growing and shrinking
a database in real time
makes me really scared.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
CARTER MORGAN: Are there people
that grow and shrink databases?
MARK MANDEL: I don't know.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I mean,
I'm pretty sure you can.
Like I know that for Bigtable,
you can totally do that.
It is not auto scaling, though.
But you need to
be quite careful,
because if you
have-- like your data
is replicated on
three nodes and it
needs to be replicated
on three nodes,
and you turn down all
of those three nodes
that happen to have
one single key,
then you lose
data, which is bad.
So I'm sure you can do it, but
you need to be really careful,
I guess.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's the sort of thing
that I'd be like OK, I'm happy
doing this in a manual way,
but I don't know if I
want a machine doing it,
at least not yet.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So what are your-- like, what
is your advice for people that
would like to run, maybe,
let's say something
typical like WordPress,
and you have the front end
and then you have the database.
Where could you
put the database?
I could personally avoid
putting in containers.
But I don't use
containers all the time.
What is your opinion on that?
CARTER MORGAN: I think if I
could host a database, I would.
This is my most candid opinion.
As in, I'd use a MySQL
service or something
like that that's hosted instead
of putting it in a container.
But with the new
features in Kubernetes,
I think we're going
to see a lot more
experimentation, a lot more
people trying it out, so maybe
new best practices
are going to emerge.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
MARK MANDEL: So maybe the
tooling is not quite there yet,
but as people start
to play with it,
it'll get there at
a certain point.
CARTER MORGAN: Right.
We talked about the
1,000-node Cassandra demo.
And again, it's a demo, so we
didn't see it in production.
We didn't see how
long it would last.
But that's really
exciting to me,
because if you can
scale up and scale down
like that with
Kubernetes, that's
almost like using
a hosted service.
So I don't know if
it's a release away
or if it's ready right now.
I want to go play after
this and check it out.
MARK MANDEL: Actually
combining that
with stuff like-- what's the
package manager for Kubernetes
called these days?
CARTER MORGAN: Helm.
MARK MANDEL: Is it Helm?
It's changed names about
three or four times, I think.
But being able to
sit around and say,
hey, I want Cassandra, boom.
I want a MongoDB
replica set-- boom.
The combination of that
and those two things,
I think that is quite powerful.
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah.
And so, again,
Kubernetes is supposed
to be a pluggable
framework like that.
So I could see that
happening in the future.
It's an exciting time to
be working on Kubernetes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So there's a lot of really
fancy new things going around.
But I feel like there's
also, many of our listeners
are still are curious about, OK,
so I've never used Kubernetes.
Where do I get started?
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah,
I'm seeing that a lot,
especially going to
conferences and giving talks.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
CARTER MORGAN: There's always
a big crowd of people that
are like, we want to know more.
To that end, Kelsey and I made
a course, Udacity scalable
microservices in Kubernetes.
It goes over everything from,
OK, I have an application.
How do I package
it and distribute
that in a doc or image?
What are some best
practices for that?
So we talk about
things like 12 Factor,
the microservices pattern,
which is the most overused term
in all of tech, containers.
We talk about the
basics of Kubernetes,
like deployment, services,
health and monitoring, secrets
and all that.
And then we get
a little bit more
advanced and talk about
deployment patterns
and rolling updates
and things like that.
So that would be
my first choice.
I'm a little biased
there, you know.
MARK MANDEL: That's fair enough.
CARTER MORGAN:
We've got interviews
with really intelligent
people like Adrian Cockroft,
former cloud
architect at Netflix,
and he talks about
the pet versus cattle
divide a little bit as
well, and the importance
of infrastructure and
why you would use it,
when to write your own,
if ever, things like that.
MARK MANDEL: That
sounds really cool.
Does it cover any of the
cluster setup side of things?
CARTER MORGAN: No.
So we--
MARK MANDEL: It's for
application developers.
CARTER MORGAN: Right.
And so that's one of
the things I'm learning.
In this role-- I'm
a DPE, so my role
is [? being ?] customer zero.
And so I've got to start using
GKE and things like that.
I've got to start doing
Kubernetes the hard way.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, it
makes it too easy for you.
CARTER MORGAN: Right.
So in this course, though,
we wanted to make it easy.
So what we did is we used
Container Engine, which
is the easiest way
to use Kubernetes.
It's pretty much one command
line, you're ready to go.
And we also use Cloud Shell,
which is-- what is it?
It's a provision VM for you
that keeps your dot files.
You have a local space
on a disk somewhere.
It's a standard
operating environment.
So it's probably the easiest way
to get started with Kubernetes,
is Cloud Shell and
Google Container Engine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, that
way everything you need
is just having a browser.
That's it.
CARTER MORGAN: Uh-huh.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
CARTER MORGAN: So it was a
pretty nice, pretty clean
setup.
We did miss-- there's a
few things in the course
that if we were doing a
Kubernetes 201 we would do,
like more production use
cases, stateful applications,
name spaces, automatic
integration with the CI tool,
continuous integration,
continuous deployment.
But yeah, if you
want to get started,
that course is the easiest,
quickest way to do it.
It's a free course--
Udacity in Google.
MARK MANDEL: Is that a
teaser, that you're actually
going to do a 201, like
an advanced course?
Is that a hint?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Because
we're now excited about it.
CARTER MORGAN: You're
excited about it?
Uh-oh.
I'm on the hook.
[LAUGHTER]
You know, I really do want to
do more advanced workshops.
So Vic Iglesias from
the solutions team
put out a really great solution
for using [? Jenkins ?] and GKE
together.
So we ran that as a workshop,
and people loved it.
They absolutely ate it up.
MARK MANDEL: I guess
if people are looking
for that advanced contact, they
can throw emails or comments
to the episode, and we'll make
sure to pass them on to Carter.
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah, absolutely.
100%.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So we're kind of running out
of time for this episode.
Is there anything
else that you'd
like to mention about
Kubernetes or GKE
that we have not mentioned this
episode or the previous one?
CARTER MORGAN: I
guess just to wrap up,
Kubernetes makes these claims.
It says, plan at scale and
never outgrow and run anywhere.
And with 1.3, we're
closer to that
than ever, because
you can run anywhere
with cluster federation, planet
scale, 2,000 nodes, 60,000
containers, and
never outgrow-- you
can go from local to
basically, again, 2,000 nodes.
So Kubernetes is
something that you
can get started with now, trying
it out really easy with GKE
and Cloud Shell, and
then take it on prem
or whatever you really need to
do to meet production needs.
It's there for you.
MARK MANDEL: Great.
Well, thanks so much
for joining us today.
CARTER MORGAN:
Thanks for having me.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, thank you.
Well, thanks so much
to Carter for spending
not one but two episodes
with us and telling us
everything we wanted to
know about Kubernetes
1.3 and Container Engine.
We're going to go through
the question of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah
CARTER MORGAN: And surprisingly,
it is also about Kubernetes.
MARK MANDEL: Is it really?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Shocking, right?
MARK MANDEL: I know.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
so I think from you.
Why don't you ask it?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
this is a question
I've heard a lot from a bunch
of people using Kubernetes.
It's really around, how
do I do local development
with Kubernetes?
We talked a little
bit about the podcast
as well, like
setting up a cluster
is a little bit difficult.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: There seems to have
been some options out there,
but there's a few of them.
Which one do I choose?
What do I do?
So if I want to do local
development in Kubernetes,
how do I do it, Carter?
CARTER MORGAN: OK,
that's a great place.
Minikube is the way to go.
So what Minikube
does is it sets you
up a local one-node
cluster using a VM.
So by default, it's
virtual biased,
but you can specify
different ones.
And then you have a lot of
the power of Kubernetes.
You don't get everything.
You don't get
ingress controllers.
You don't get load balancers.
But for most of your day-to-day
use on a single-node machine,
you can try it out, and then
you can take that and just
go and run the same thing
that you're running locally
on a provider.
MARK MANDEL: So I know in
previous local versions
of Kubernetes, I was limited by
the number of pods I could run,
like I couldn't
run more than, say,
one pod of a particular thing.
Is that limitation still
in place with Minikube,
or am I just kind of
resource controlled
based on how big my VM is
more than anything else?
CARTER MORGAN: You're
going to the node now,
so you have one node.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
So I can run multiples of those
containers within that node,
and very similar to what
I would run at scale,
but maybe just slightly smaller.
CARTER MORGAN: Uh-huh.
And now Minikube is
ongoing, so it's not
like the final finished product.
Off the top of my head,
I can't remember what
they're thinking about adding.
But again, you don't get, say,
the load balancers or ingress.
But you can set up
deployments and all the--
MARK MANDEL: All the good stuff.
CARTER MORGAN: All
the good stuff.
MARK MANDEL: All the good stuff.
But there's more stuff coming,
and they're really like,
that's the one true way of
doing local development.
Ooh, ooh, we have
some contention.
CARTER MORGAN: Well,
no, I just-- I always
get nervous when you say
one true way to do anything.
MARK MANDEL: For now.
For now.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, that is true.
CARTER MORGAN: Especially
because Kubernetes
wants to be so open.
But if I was going to do
local development right now,
and what I've been playing
with myself, is Minikube.
MARK MANDEL: That's fair.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So thanks
again to Carter Morgan
to spend with us two long
episodes on Kubernetes and GKE,
and not only that,
but also staying
to answer the question
of the week today.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, absolutely.
Thanks so much for that--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, good job--
MARK MANDEL: --Minikube circle.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So we're about to
finish, but before
finishing I would like to
remind our listeners on how
they can send us cool
things of the week.
Or if they have any other
questions or proposals
for topics, we're also
very interested in that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So if they want to reach us by
email, where can they reach us?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It is
hello@GCPpodcast.com.
MARK MANDEL: Our website is--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It is
either GCPpodcast.com
or Cloud.Google.com/podcast.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
If they want to speak
to us on Reddit?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It is on
the subreddit r/GCPpodcast.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
If they want to
reach us on Twitter?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It is @GCPpodcast.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
If they want to
reach us on Google+?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It is +GCPpodcast.
MARK MANDEL: And the channel
name in the GCP Slack community
is--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Podcast?
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
There you go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I was not
complete sure about that one.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
Well, Francesc, thank you
again for joining me this week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you,
and talk to you all next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]